let's go next to our caller from the
nine one six area code who's calling
today from nine one six
I needed this Curtis hey Curtis what's
up yeah Riggs talk to you thanks for
doing what you do my pleasure um quick
question I just thought maybe you could
try to clarify for me um someone during
the Korean election interference
conspiracy theory is that not
contradictory to the set rich conspiracy
theory how so that says this might could
be interesting what do you mean well
from a you know conservative perspective
isn't it two different ways of
explaining that the DNC us actor the
emails were stolen and or are they
different different attacks on the
election you know are is I think
separate shred allegedly stole some
emails and get passed on to WikiLeaks
right where Ukraine theory is that the
Ukrainians hacked the DNC server and
they provided it that they released it
to hurt the election so those not
contradictory statements that some
conservatives are using in other words
the tracking of the DNC is being by some
on some conspiracy theorists being
attributed to Seth rich and by other
conspiracy theorists being attributed to
Ukraine and how could both be true they
seem like two different explanations for
the same event yeah I mean if you see
like people like Andy talking about both
of those conspiracy theories don't they
have to choose one
they really don't actually that's the
funny thing I mean because of their odd
so two things on that I mean number one
Hannity is not talking about Seth rich
anymore and honestly I actually I don't
even want to say for sure
I don't remember specifically whether
Hannity was one of the people pushing
the Seth rich thing now I'm trying to
think I guess maybe he was in any case
regardless I don't think you're seeing
people push both at the same time Seth
rich was a couple years ago and you saw
some lingering from it but they've
shifted I don't if they were pushing
them both the same
time it would be more cartoonishly
hypocritical but I think they've just
moved on from one to the other well
Kennedy definitely was pushed in the
saturates thing at one time and now it
seems like these place from the Ukraine
theory and I don't I think they should
just be obviously hypocrisy is not
something that really registers a lot of
these people but to try to you know deny
the facts and use contradictory
conspiracy theories it seems pretty
blatant well this is not a new thing I
listened on it this has been their mo
look at look at with for example the
Russia stuff for a while it was we had
no contacts with Russia or if we did
they were completely fine and legal and
we would do it again like those are also
conflicts right but it just doesn't
matter it's come up with something for
anybody Trump did this with health
insurance for a while it was I'm gonna
do a on health care I'm gonna do B on
health care I'm gonna do C on health
care they were all mutually exclusive
but it was sort of like pick one that
sounds good and then that's why you
should vote for Trump that this is
nothing new right I agree it's it's
constant changes story changes you know
whatever it takes to get them through
the next month the scandal that's
exactly right Curtis I appreciate the
call thank you thanks David all right
take care